brady kids are back at it for hgtv's
upcoming series of very brady
renovations you and i were there for the
groundbreaking look yes we lost our
minds and we felt the excitement and the
anticipation but as you'll see i don't
think the brady bunch cast really knew
what was about to go down kids let's get
to work this is better than therapy this
is therapy yeah
this is gonna be the most epic
renovation ever
[Music]
and i told him i'm great with it with a
hammer i'm great cutting drywall i can
and i can fix the plumbing we've been
knocking things down we've been tearing
things up
they've been at it for seven weeks now
on day one we got to see the brady
bunches first look at their colossal
remodel oh wow
when i first stepped inside
i was shocked it's not what you expect
[Music]
of course the brady interiors were shot
on a hollywood soundstage this house was
only used for exterior shots i have only
been here one time in my life previous
to today have you swung a hammer yet in
there no no that's that's coming today
though
this planter which actually had flowers
in it it's an old hot tub who knew
the planter that we're going to put
there to match the brady house was on
wheels you could roll it away one two
three
helping with a very brady renovation our
hgtv hosts such as the property brothers
and jasmine raw so the next step is this
is gonna become a closet it's the first
thing you see when you walk into the
brady house it has to be perfect i had a
conversation with greg years ago in that
closet
the intent to recreate the brady
interior exactly inside the bathrooms it
was a faux pas to show a toilet back
then so there were no toilets
there you go
the owners built the wall in the front
yard only to keep the looky-loos away so
it's gotta go
[Music]
nice in that famous staircase it
actually led to nowhere we had to try to
hide from the camera and so we'd like
flirt up there and like you know
it was like our own brady type
so many memories i mean you know it's
it's really kind of strange being here
without
bob and florence and annie but they're
with us florence would have been rolling
up her sleeve yeah she'd have been right
there with me with the hammer and anne
would have been right there cooking
lunch for us i cannot wait for this
renovation this year it's gonna be so
much fun covering this whole thing by
the way fans can follow along and see
the progress by going to hgtv.com
[Music]